في كل انحاء ايران وفي مختلف المدن
احتجاجات مستمره بالانقطاع في منطقه ستار
خان بطهران وفي بلده بنفسه في كراج حيث
اطلقت قوه الامن اشعه الليزر على منازل
المواطنين بالاضافه الى تفجير قنابل صوتيه
كما امت الاحتجاجات اصفهان ومحافظات جيلان
ايضا بالموازنه مع ذلك اضرابات عامه
الاسواق والجامعات عمال الصناعه اضربوا عن
العمل كنوع من المشاركه في الحركه
ياتي هذا في وقت وصل قائد الحرس الثوري
تهديد المحتاجين ملقيا باللوم من جديد على
اطراف خارجيه ومتهم اياها بتاجيل نار
الفتنه خامنئي من جهته وصف ما يجري
بالمؤامره والفتنه التي يحيقها اداء ايران
في حين قالت ابنه شقيقته في شريط فيديو من
مكان اعتقالها في طهران ان على المجتمع
الدولي وقفه التعاون والتفاعل مع النظام
الايراني الحالي التطورات اعاقبت احتجاجات
واسعه في مدينه بركان بمحافظه اذربيجان
الغربيه ردت عليها الشرطه بنشر المزيد من
قوتها
الاعتقالات في صفوف الصحفيين متواصله ايضا
من خلال القاء القبض على الصحفيه الرياضيه
الايرانيون في لندن تلقيهم تهديدات من
طهران لمنعهم من تغطيه الاحتجاجات وفي
كندا معارضون ايراني قالوا انهم يخضعون
للمراقبه ويتعرضون للتهديد من طهران هذا
واكد القضاء الايراني ان مغني الراب تو
ماتش صالح المعتقل منذ اواخر اكتوبر يمكن
ان يعاقب بالاعدام بعد ما ادلى بتصريحات
قال فيها ان النظام الايراني مستعد لقتل
امه باكملها في سبيل الاحتفاظ بالسلطه
والاموال والاسلحه وفق تعبيره بلال
الوجديني العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]